wird es wieder möglich sein im sommer
nach frankreich italien zumindest in
europa zu bereisen was denken sie also
erst mal stimmt das was sie sagen weil
wir stellen das auch fest im
krisenreaktionszentrum die anrufe die
dort eingehen sind mittlerweile in der
mehrzahl solche leute fragen wann sie
wieder in urlaub fahren können und wenn
ich die gelegenheit nutzen dürfte die
leute aufzurufen nicht im
krisenreaktionszentrum anzurufen um zu
fragen wann sie wieder in urlaub kommen
können denn also irgendwie überlastet
die telefonleitung erhalten sie sind
nicht überlastet weil die meisten
zurückgebracht worden sind aber die
meisten wollen jetzt wissen wir wann sie
wieder in urlaub fahren können nachdem
jetzt die meisten die gestrandet sind
zurückgebracht worden wir wollen dieses
krisenreaktionszentrum aber offenheit
für krisenfälle nach wie vor die frage
wann man wieder in urlaub fahren kann
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt kann ich sehe ich
überhaupt keinen grund die reisewarnung
aufzuheben
es bestehen ja in den meisten ländern
einreisebeschränkungen bis hin zu
verboten das heißt man kommt ja sowieso
nicht mehr weg aber selbst dort wo es
möglich ist müssen wir davon ausgehen
dass einzelne länder den sogenannten
peak noch nicht erreicht haben dass die
infektionszahlen weiter steigen und
möglicherweise denen das schlimmste noch
bevorsteht und wenn man dort angekommen
ist und die lage sich dort
verschlechtert man in zwei wochen
möglicherweise nicht mehr wegkommt und
wir werden eine solche rückholaktion wie
die 240.000 menschen die wir zurück
gebracht haben
im sommer nicht noch mal machen können
das heißt wir sind sehr sehr sorgfältig
schauen uns das an wir werden das jetzt
in den nächsten wochen weiter verfolgen
natürlich wollen wir auch dass die
menschen im sommer ihren urlaub machen
können aber wir können die reisewarnung
nur dann aufheben wenn wir auch sicher
sind dass man überhaupt weg kommt dass
die menschen auch wieder zurückkommen
und nur dann ist es verantwortbar die
reisewarnung aufzuheben die geht jetzt
bis anfang mai wir werden ende april
anfang mai noch einmal entscheiden je
nachdem wie die lage dann ist ob es
hinweise gibt dieser reisewarnung
aufzuheben zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt
gibt es diese hin
sie nicht planen sie persönlich dann im
sommer ihren urlaub in deutschland oder
haben sie noch hoffnung dass es
funktionieren kann worden dass hin zu
rein also im moment komme ich ja noch
gar nicht dazu
urlaubsplanung zu kümmern
ich hätte es aber auch ehrlich gesagt im
moment nicht wenn ich auch mit anderen
sachen beschäftigt wäre ich glaube es
ist vernünftig noch abzuwarten um zu
sehen überhaupt zu sehen wo kann man
urlaub machen also ich meine länder die
vielleicht schön sind und wo man schon
oft urlaub gemacht hat in denen es
ausgangssperren gibt da kann man ja
keinen urlaub machen und der urlaub soll
ja auch urlaub sein und sich auch so an
führen und das ist an vielen stellen der
welt im moment nicht mehr fallen und
wenn es nur die klarheit ist sollte man
noch abwarten wenn sie die zahlen sehen
die entwicklung des virus kann man dann
sagen er keine hoffnung für den sommer
ich finde man muss immer optimistisch
umgehen allerdings zum gegenwärtigen
zeitpunkt ich kann ja nur im moment
entscheiden
aufgrund der situation wie sie jetzt ist
und jetzt liegt der internationale
flugverkehr der komplette reiseverkehr
am boden und es gibt viele länder mit
ausgangssperren es gibt viele ländern in
denen die flughäfen nach wie vor
geschlossen sind es gibt keinen einzigen
anlass für mich diese reisewarnung zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt aufzuheben
und solange sich daran nichts verändert
wird die reisewarnung nicht aufgehoben
werden